wait hold up y'all call me up here for
one line in a stupid skit it's okay just
take your seat please
all right I know we're sorry thank you
from a hilarious opening number to some
jokes that didn't land et is taking a
look at the best and worst moments of
the 70th Primetime Emmys and it was
Chrissy Teigen who brought the laughs
after hosts Michael che and Colin Jost
made this controversial joke
congratulations to Laurie Metcalf yeah
Wow that's incredible you know how great
an actress you have to be to get
nominated for Roseanne now that's like
nominating a cop for a Beatty award
doesn't happen Henry Winkler gave us all
the feels after winning his first Emmy
ever I only had 37 seconds I wrote this
43 years ago okay
okay can I just say skip Brittenham said
to me a long time ago if you stay at the
table long enough the chips come to you
and tonight I got to clear the table and
when Alex Borstein won the Emmy for
Supporting Actress in a comedy series
for her role in the marvelous mrs. nasal
I went without the bra she used her time
at the mic to bless us with these sage
words of wisdom ladies when you use a
public restroom sit down if you sit we
can all sit but she wasn't the only star
dishing out advice Michael Douglas had
this to say to all the losers in the
room know that you were cheated you were
robbed that's a fact let that fire burn
in your belly until your cold dead body
is in a pine box six feet deep clutching
all its Emmys to its chest then there
was this sweet moment you wonder why I
don't like to call you my girlfriend
because I want to call you my wife Glenn
Weiss the director of the Oscars popped
the question to his girlfriend after
his big win will you marry me but it
wasn't all laughs and feel-good moments
Benedict Cumberbatch did not seem amused
when the host made a joke at his expense
a limited series is when a movie star
reaches the limit on all of their credit
cards so they have to do television
Cumberbatch knows what I'm talking about
get some money my awkward and nothing
was creepier than this surprise
appearance you may have missed yep
that's seemingly Donald Glover dressed
in character as Teddy Perkins from his
hit show Atlanta
[Applause]
[Music]